[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نص صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
في ايران احتجاج صامت لكن رسالته كسرت كل
الحواجز وجنرال يقر بمقتل اكثر من 300
شخصا في الاحتجاجات
يفتحوا النار على ابل ويؤكد ان الشركه
هددت بحدد تويتر من مجارها ويتهمها باخذ
ضريبه سريه
مباريات الحاسمه في كاس العالم البرازيل
يحجز مقعده في الدوري النهائي وتفوق لافت
للفرق الافريقي
مجلس سياده السودانيه يجدد الخناقه على
النقابات المهنيه وقف وانشطه وحصر ارصده
وسلب للسلطان
[موسيقى]
وسعت مؤقتا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه بات
التحدي هو السمه الغالبه على نهج المحتجين
الايرانيين لم يعرف الياس طريقا لهم رغم
كل ما يمارس بحقهم من قمع وعنف وصل حد
القتل والاعتقال والاعدام وفي ابرز صوره
على تحدي المحتاجين خروج مجموعه من النساء
والممثلات الايرانيات اليوم في احتجاج
صامت لكن صوته صدح عاليا في ايران والعالم
اكبر
ورغم سياستها في التستر على الجرائم اقر
جنرال ايراني بمقتل اكثر من 300 شخصا في
الاحتجاجات التي تشهدها البلاد مع العلم
ان منظماتي حقوق الانسان اعلنت ان اكثر من
40 150 شخصا قتلوا منذ بدء الاحتجاجات بعد
وفاه مهسئه امينه
الاساليب الوحشيه التي انتهجها النظام
الايراني ضد المتظاهرين منذ اليوم الاول
بات اليوم يتهرب منها امام التحقيقات
الدوليه وزاره الخارجيه الايرانيه افادت
بان طهران سترفض التعاون مع لجنه تقص
الحقائق التي شكلتها الامم المتحده اخيرا
واحتجاجا على قرار مجلس حقوق الانسان
استدعت ايران السفيره الالمانيه لديها بعد
ما قدمت بلده مشروع قرار امام مجلس حقوق
الانسان التابعي للامم المتحده نتج عن
تبنيه تشكيل لجنه تحقيق دوليه في قمع
الاحتجاجات في ايران ونذكره بان لجنه
التحقيق
والتحقيق الصادر بها تكليفات من الامم
المتحده يتزايد واستخدامها للتصدي لحالات
الانتهاكات الخطيره للقانون الانساني
الدولي والقانون الدولي لحقوق الانسان
سواء كانت طويله الامد او ناجمه عن احداث
مفاجاه ثلاجات التي شكلتها الامم المتحده
في ايران سيتولى مهام التحقيق في
الانتهاكات التي مارسها النظام بحق
المتظاهرين منذ للعب احتجاجات سواء بالقتل
او الاعتقالات او استخدام العنف او تنفيذي
حكم الاعدام بحق المعتقلين
ايران كما قالت رسميا لن تتعاون على
الاطلاق مع هذه اللجنه السياسيه التي اطلق
عليها اسم لجنه تقص الحقائق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
معنى من لندن البحث في الشونه الايرانيه
عارف نصر استاذ عارف اهلا بكم معنا
بدايتهم كيف تقرا اعتراف الجنرال الايراني
بسقوط 300 قتيل في هذه الاحتجاجات
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهده العربيه الكرام
انا احتفظ بان هذا الامر هو ناتج من كون
ربما هنالك خشيه من من
ربما الاجماع الدولي وخاصه قضيه لجنه تغسل
حقائق على على الصعيد الاموي وبالتالي
هنالك حاجه ايرانيه الى الاعتراف بجزء من
هذه
المجازر التي ارتكبت في بلوشستان وكذلك في
همم في كردستان وباغي مناطق غيران خاصه
وان خاصه في القضيه البلوشيه وفي المغتلى
في الجمعه السوداء كما عرفت من شانها ان
تفتح الباب على عده اصعده منها اجانب همم
نحن نعلم بان معظم العقد طويل الامد الصين
الايراني يقع في بانوشستان وكذلك الحدود
بين بلوجستان وافغانستان وكذلك باكستان
مفتوحه وبالتالي لا يريدون تصعيد هذا خلاف
من هنا يريدون الاعتراف بهذا الامر ليكون
هناك يعني لجنه التقصف الحقائق التي نتجت
عن قرار مجلس حقوق الانسان اثارت غضب
السلطات الايرانيه وقامت باستدعاء السفير
الالماني في همم طهران لماذا يعني تثير
همم او يثير هذا القرار غضب النظام في
طهران
همم طبعا لان انا همم عندما اتيت بهذه
الشواهد اردت ان اقول هذا الامر بانه
هنالك ستكون لجنه تغذي حقائق داخليه
وبالتالي هذا التصريح للجنرال حجيان انما
هو حج زياده يفتح الباب لجنه التخصص
الحقائق الداخليه والاعتراف ببعض هذه
الملفات الداخليه اما فيما يتعلق
بجانب الخارجي وربما همم لجنه تقصى
الحقائق الدوليه فهي هنالك ثلاثه امور
رئيسيه الاول لان ربما من خلال هذه اللجنه
سيكون هنالك اجماع دوري وهذه الاجماع
الدولي يخيف همم طهران الجانب الثاني يميت
الملف النووي ومتابعه الغرب لهذا الملف
لان ستفرض على ضوئه مجموعه من
العقوبات المتعلقه بحقوق الانسان والامر
الثالث سيفتح الباب
تحاور مع المعارضه الايرانيه من هنا ان
نحتقد بان همم هذا الامر هو الذي يغلق همم
الجانب الايراني ويريدون ان يفتحوا لجنه
ما يقلق النظام الايراني الاستاذ اا عارف
هناك من يرى ان هذه الاحتجاجات في ايران
هي احتجاجات مختلفه عن سابقاتها بالنظر
الى اا طول امامها ونفسها الطويل كذلك
والشعارات التي بات ترفعها التي تحولت
لدعوات للاطاحه بالدوله الدينيه في ايران
التي تحكم منذ عام
79 هل ترى همم يعني همم
انقساما دعنا نقول داخل النظام الايراني
هناك جزء بالفعل داخل النظام يؤيد مطالب
المحتاجين ام لا
يعني اذا ما حلت هذا السؤال الى ربما حوار
او اخر لغاء خامني هو حاول ان يطرح بصيغه
الغايب على موضوعين قال بان البعض يطرحون
بان علينا ان نسمع صوت الشارع وثم حاول ان
يلتفعل هذا الامر وكذلك قال او رفض
اخر لقائه مع البسيج قضيه الاستفتاء العام
لذلك ان دل على شيء يدل بان همم هنالك
كثير ربما التيار الداخلي حتى التيار
الاصولي او التيار الاصلاحي يريد من
النظام او طالب بالفعل طالب المرشد
الايراني باجراء بعض التنازلات وكذلك
تقيرات دستوريه ونحن نعلم ايضا بان محمد
خاتم كما صرح الطرح بعثه برساله الى خامنه
طالب به عن همم ان يفعل همم خيرات
الدستوريه لكنما بجميع الاحوال المرشد
الايراني لا يسقي الى
حتى اذا كان هذا الطرف مقربي اليك عارف
نصر الباحث في شان الايراني من لندن شكرا
جزيلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مع ريكو تويتر لا تنتهي في اخر فصولها هجم
الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه الى الماسك هاجم
شركه ابل بعد وقفها الاعلان على تويتر
وطلبها بنشر اجراءات الرقابه لحمايه
عملائها وقال ماسك في السلسله تغريدات على
تويتر هددت بحجم تطبيق تويتر من مجالها
دون ابلاغهم بالاسباب عقل باخذ ضريبه سريه
بمقدار 30% من مطوري التطبيقات عبر متجر
جيرها كما طرح ماسك على نشاط في تويتر
التصويت على نشر شركه ابل لاجراءات
الرقابه لديها
عموما مشاكله كثيره اضحك تعانيها منصه
تويتر بعد قرارات الملك الجديد
منهم مديرون كبار ومسؤول الرقابه
امنيه واعصاب
[موسيقى]
وجدل اخر يدور حول تويتر يتعلق بقدره
المنصه على مراقبه ومحاسبه الحسابات
المخالفه بعد اعلان الى الماسك عفوا عاما
على حسابات محظوره
الامان الخصوصيه الرسائل الخطره مفاتيح
اساسيه كانت محطه نقاش بعد استحواذ ايلون
ماسك على منصه تويتر قرارات متسارعه
للملياردير الامريكيه فتحت جدلا واسعا بين
الخبراء ومستخدميه تويتر لكن قراره الاخير
باصدار عفو عام عن الحسابات المجمده كان
الابرز موافقه اغلبيه مستخدمي العصفور
الازرق على استفتاء ماسك حول فك حظر
الحسابات المجمده لا تعني موافقه الجميع
او انه قرار لا يتحمل عواقبه
[تصفيق]
خطط واله النصب قد تهدد بعوده خطابات
الكراهيه الى تويتر
حتى قبل تحركات اعاده الحسابات المحظوره
الا ان ذلك القرار انذار بعوده الدعوه
للعنف الا ان المالك الجديد لتويتر لديه
وجهه نظر اخرى لخصها بالارقام بحسب
احصاءات نشرها ماسك عن انجازات منصه منذ
استحواذه عليها فبات خطاب الكراهيه على
تويتر اقل بقرابه الثلث اعتبارا من الثالث
عشر من نوفمبر مقارنه بمنتصف اكتوبر من
العام الماضي اي انخفاض من 10 ملايين الى
مليون ونصف المليون
[تصفيق]
المتابعون لشؤون تويتر يرون ان السياسات
الارتجاريه التي اتخذها ماسك في المنصه
ستعود عليه بالسلب خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالتحكم في حريه التعبير والمعايير
المنظمه له فكيف لتويتر ان تطبق قواعد
المحتوى في وقت يعفو فيه مصر عن حسابات
المحظوره لاسباب بعضها يتعلق بخطابات
الكراهيه والعنف من جهه ومن جهه اخرى موجه
من الطرد والاستقالات ادت لتقليس عدد
الموظفين بشكل كبير جزء منهم وظيفته
الاساسيه مراقبه واتخاذ اجراءات ضد
الحسابات المخالفه للقواعد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في شمال سوريا
الامريكي على مدى اكثر من اسبوع لكن يبدو
ان الموازين قد تغيرت وبات ثم تتفاهم تركي
الروسي في القامشلي وهو السماح بنشر الجيش
السوري عوضا عن القوات الكرديه على الحدود
التركيه والهدف الضغط على جسد قوه سوريا
الديمقرا الديمقراطيه تسليم مناطقها
الحدوديه مع تركيا للنظام السوري لكن قصد
رفضت المقترح الروسي وقررت مواجهه العمليه
العسكريه التركيه وان كانت تطالب واشنطن
بالضغط على انقره لمنعها من القيام بذلك
ويبدو ان مصالح موسكو مع تركيا تفوقت على
الضغط الروسي لوقف الهجمات في شمال سوريا
حيث تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان الى عوده
العلاقات مع النظام السوري على غرار
التقارب الاخير مع مصر
كان لدينا اجتماع ضيق نطاق مع الرئيس
المصري واتفقنا على اجتماعات وزراء بلدينا
التي سيتم تطويرها وتوعها سنبدل
الاجتماعات على نطاق الضيق ومن ثم سنتبادل
الزيارات ونطورها كذلك الامر بالنسبه
لسوريا يمكن ان يحدث نفس الشيء كما حصل مع
مصر وهناك امكانيه لعوده الامور الى
نصابها مع سوريا
وفي الوقت الذي لم يلمس فيه الاكراد واي
مؤشرات على استعدادات العسكريه تركيه لشن
عمليه بريه شمال سوريا اكد مسؤولون اتراك
اليوم ان الجيش لا يحتاج الا لايام قليله
ليكون جاهزا بشكل كامل لعمليه التوغل في
شمال سوريا واشار المسؤولون ان العمليه
البريه تستهدف مناطق منبج وعين العرب
كوباني وترفعه لربط تلك المناطق
لكن عاده التشكيك بتنفيذ العمليه البريه
خصوصا بعد انتهاء كلمه الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان في اجتماعي مجلس الوزراء من
دون اي اشاره او اعلان عن الهجوم البري
وخلال مؤتمر صحفي عقب الاجتماع الحكومي
قال اردوغان ان الجيش سيواصل عمليته ضد من
اسمائهم بالتنبات الارهابيه حتى القضاء
على اخر كارهم اضاف اردوغان انقر لن تطلب
اذن من اي جهه لحمايه حدودها على حد
تعبيره
من بيروت ينضم الينا خور الدنيا الباحث
السياسي سيد خورشيد اهلا بكم معنا في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه هل هناك عمليه
بريه تركيه في شمال سوريا ام لا
تحياتي لك واهل مشاهدينا العربيه حتى الان
ااا استطيع القول انه ليست هناك مؤشرات
حقيقيه يمكن البناء عليها بان عمليه بريه
ستتم لماذا
الى الان ليست هناك لا موافقه الروسيه ولا
موافقه امريكيه على مثل هذه العمليه
وفي السياسه لا اعتقد ان اردوغان يمكن ان
يقوم بمثل هذا الامر نظرا لانه سيترتب
عليه تداعيات كثيره المؤشر الثاني وهو
الوضع الميداني على الارض الى الان عندما
كانت تركيا سابقا في عمليات ما يسمى درع
الفرات غصن الزيتون بعد السلام تكون خلال
ساعات بقصف جوي مكثف ومن ثم تبدا العمليه
البريه الان مره اكثر من اسبوع واحد
العمليه الجويه التركيه ولم نشاهد مثل هذا
القصر ايضا التقارير التي تاتي من الحدود
السوريه
ضخمه على الارض على المستوى رغم الحديث
قال الاعلامي والدعاء بان عمليه بريه
وشيكه اكثر من ذلك عندما يشدد المسؤولون
الاتراك به دوما ان خلال ساعات ستكون
عمليه وينبع كل هذا الوقت في اعتقادي ان
هذا يشير لان هناك ايضا مؤشر لافت هو
تلميح اردوغان الى امكانيه المصالحه مع
النظام السوري في دمشق
والحديث الان على ربما المقترح الروسي
كذلك على انه عوده قوات النظام على حساب
قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه للانتشار على
الحدود السوريه التركيه همم الى اي حد
يمكن ان يتحقق هذا يعني ولا نعلم يعني
حقيقه الموقف الامريكي من هذا المقترح
يعني اولا ثاني اسمي هذا الامر بنوع
المعادله التاليه ضجيج انقر وصمت دمشق كل
يوم نسمع تصريحات من الرئيس التركي من
المتحدثين باسمه من وزاره الخارجيه انهم
مستعدون لفتح صفحه جديده مع دمشق
ولقاء بين الرئيس اردوغان والرئيس بشار
الاسد
في الاعلام اما على الارض الواقع مختلف
هناك صدام عسكري
التصعيد جاري على قدم وساق تركيا الى هذه
اللحظه تدخل معداتها جنود جداد الى داخل
الاراضي التي تحتلها في سوريا وبالتالي
هناك معادله اخرى ما هي انا باعتقاعدين
بسالتين المساله الاولى هي تتعلق بالداخل
التركي اردوغان يدور جيدا ان الملف السوري
وتحديد الملف اللاجئين اصبح علما عليه في
الداخل والمعارضه استغلت هذه الورقه كي
تكون بدايه الحمله الانتخابيه قال لي انا
باعتقادي اردوغان لجا الى استخدام ورقه
المصالحه مع دمشق خاصه ان المعارضه كانت
تقول انها مستعده حل هذه الازمه اذا فازت
بالانتخابات من خلال الذهاب الى دمشق
مباشره الان اردوغان يسابق الى المعارضه
من المعارضه بقول نفس القضيه لساحه هذه
ورقه من المعارضه لان الثانيه يتعلق بما
تفضلت به الحديث اردوغان يحاول من خلال
سياسه
امريكيا ها هو الموقف الامريكي على الخبر
العاجل الان البيت الابيض يقول اي عمليه
عسكريه في سوريا يمكن ان تقوض جهود مكافحه
داعش همم مره اخرى يعني هذا موقف امريكي
واضح حياه الى اذن العمليه العسكريه
التركيه التي تلوح بها في شمال سوريا يقول
انه يمكن ان تقوض جهود مكافحه داعش ربما
الحديث هنا عن سجون داعش التي تسيطر عليها
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قصد هل يفهم من
هذا انه الرفض يعني انه همم يمكن للاكراد
ان يرتاحوا بان تركيا لن تتغل
بعدين لا يمكن القول ان الكود لن
يرتاحوا لمجرد مثل هذه التصريحات وهذه
التصريحات حقيقه غير كافيه وهي ربما تعبر
عن نوع من الضبابيه نعم هناك تطور في
الموقف الامريكي لجهه رفض اي عمليه عسكريه
تركيه ولكن ما الذي يحصل الان هو عمليا
هدد للاصدقاء وعمليا تركيا قصفت حتى
السجون التي فيها داعش وقتلت من قوات
الحمايه هناك ايضا ده تركي دمرت البنيه
التحتيه التي تقوم بتامين دوله الحياه ليه
ملايين الناس هناك ترجع الى الان ربما حتى
ان تغامر القيام بنوع من العمليه محدوده
وتحدي حتى موقفي موسكو واشنطن نظر لان
اردوغان كما يقال صعد الى الشجره ولا
يستطيع النزول عنها ما لم يقوم بعمليه ماء
لكن في الاجماع الى الان الموقف الروسي
الامريكي دعني اقول بشكل واضح هو الرافض
لاي عمليه عسكريه تركيه مناطق شمال شرق
سوريا نظر لان مثل هذا الامر سيؤدي الى
تغيير في المعادلات وفي الموازين العسكريه
التي يحرص الان الجميع ربما الحفاظ عليها
لحين ربما ايجاد متغيرات او معطيات جديده
يمكن ان تساعد على حل الازمه السوريه في
حين ما يرتقون به تركيا هو فضل عن التدمير
لاهاليه تلك المنطقه وضرب البنيه التحتيه
هو يؤدي الى صوت اوراق من جديد
حديثه عن مكافحه الارهاب
ليس سوى مباريات
السياسيه من بيروت شكرا جزيلا لك
نروح لا تركيا تستقبلنا لا دول برا
تستخدمنا
عيال ارواح
يعني ما تقدر العيله بالليل بالنهار
ناجحين صار لنا عشر سنين نازحين عم نتحول
من منطقه المنطقه
حدود تركيا
[موسيقى]
والى تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه يبدو ان
القزقه الروسيه المستمر على البنى التحتيه
في اوكرانيا جعل السلطات الاوكرانيه تتوقع
سيناريوهات المختلفه للوضع في العاصمه كيف
عمده
الاخلاء الجزئي لسكان الى الضواحي في حال
حدوث اسوا سيناريو ممكن فيما يخص وضع
امدادات الطاقه الكهربائيه
لقطع التيار الكهربائي عن مناطق في انحاء
البلاد بعد انتكاسه في جهودها لاصلاح
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه التي تضررت اثرها
هجمات صاروخيه الروسيه
اما في خلص ورغم الانسحاب الروسي منها
تشهدوا المدينه قصفا اوكرانيا روسيا
متبادلا اذ تحاول القوات الاوكرانيه ضربه
خطوط الامداد بين نهر دنبرو والقرم في حين
تسعى القوه الروسيه الى ضرب البنيه تحتيه
الاوكرانيه وقد حذرت الدفاع البريطانيه من
صعوبه الوضع في خرسن مع القصص المدفعيه
الروسيه المتكرر بشكل يومي وقالت ان
المدينه معربه لخطر بالغ لانها لا تزال في
نطاق معظم انظمه مدفعيه الروسيه
المتميزه في الضفه الشرقيه لنهر
فيما على طول خط الجبهه شرقي اوكرانيا
للدقه اكثر في اقليم دوم بس تحتدم المعارك
ايضا ولم يبقى صوت بين طرفي النزاع سوا
صوت الصواريخ الجيش الاوكرانيه فدى بان
قصطا روسيا مكتفا استهدفا البنيه التحتيه
في مقاطعه دينيبرو وسطى جنوبي اوكرانيا
اضافه الى تعرض ضواحي ذا فولوجيا لقصف
بالصواريخ دون وقوع اصابات من جهاتها
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها
صدتها جامعه الاوكرانيه على محورين
[تصفيق]
وفي الوقت الذي يبدل فيه الغرب وجهودا
حديثه لتلبيه الطلب على المزيد من الاسلحه
الاوكرانيا خصوصا بعد الانباء التي تحدثت
عن تقلص مخزون السلاح تدرس وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه اقتراحا من شركه بوينج لتزويد
اوكرانيا بقنابل دقيقه صغيره ورخيصه يتم
تثبيتها على صواريخ متوفره بكثره مصادر في
هذه الصناعه اشارت الى ان المنظومه التي
اقترحتها بوينج والتي يطلق عليها اسم
قنبله ذات قطر صغير تطلق من الارض هي
واحده ست خطه الانتاج الاخيره جديده
لاوكرانيا وحلفاء واشنطن في اوروبا
تجمع بين قنبله 39 ذات القطر الصغير ومحرك
الصواريخ امس 26 وكلاهما متوفر في مخزونات
الولايات المتحده لكن كيف ستغير هذه
القنابل من واقع المعركه على الارض سيما
وانها بحسب الفن تسمح بتوجيه ضربات خلف
الخطوط الروسي وفي ملف السلاح ايضا اعلن
رئيس منظمه حظر الاسلحه الكيميائيه
فرناندو الياس ان الحرب في اوكرانيا زادت
من خطر استخدام اسلحه الدمار الشامل بما
في ذلك الذخائر الكيميائيه فقال ارياه
سيدنا منظمه حظر الاسلحه الكيميائيه تواصل
متابعه هذا الوضع الخطير عن كتب وتبقى على
اتصال بالممثلين الدائمين للاتحاد الروسي
واوكرانيا بدوره اعتبر المندوب الروسيه ان
المنظمه تتجاهل تقارير الاستفزازات
الاوكرانيه باستخدام الاسلحه الكيميائيه
[موسيقى]
نذهب الان الى باكستان وبعد نحو سته اشهر
على الهدنه هناك اعلنت حركه طالبان
باكستان في قرار المقلق الغاء اتفاقي وقف
اطلاق النار الذي تم توصله اليه مع
الحكومه الباكستانيه بل يهدد طالبان
الباكستانيه باستئناف العنف وامرت مقاتلها
بشنها جمال في انحاء البلاد رغم ان طالبان
الافغانيه منفصله عن طالبان الباكستانيه
الا ان الحركتين تتشاركان
[موسيقى]
معنى من اسلام اباد جاويد صديق مدير
وتحرير صحيفه سيجاويد اهلا بك معنا في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه لماذا انقلب
الطالبان باكستان على الاتفاق مع الحكومه
الباكستانيه
1 2 3
الحركه ليس تراديه
ما تقوم به باكستان في الوقت الراهن
بالاساس
باكستان كانت ترغب من هذه العناصر ان تظل
تتبنى موقفا سلما وان تنتهي عن مهاجمتي
باكستان
بدل من القيام بانشطه ارهابيه داخل
ورغبت باكستان ايضا من حركه طالبان
باكستان بعد
السلطه
ان يتوصل الى نوع من الاتفاق السلمي مع
باكستاني وطالبا
افغانستان وصلت الى السلطه الان وهي قد
رغي بث من حركه طالبان باكستان تتواصل الى
اتفاق مال الحكومه وقد جرت مفاوضات همم
خلف الابواب
المصاده وقد استمرت لشهور طويله لكننا
هذه المفاوضات لم تنجح على الرغم من
الهدنه التي تم التوصل اليها بين الجانبين
ولكن الكثير من الانتهاكات لهذه الهدنه
همم الجيش الباكستاني وقوات الامن
الباكستانيه تعرضت لي هجمات المتكرره من
قبل حركه
السبب الذي ادى الى انهيار هذه الهدنه بين
الجانبين
اسلام اباد
جمال ربانستان
[موسيقى]
باكستان ليس لديها الرغبه في
الوصول الى هذا الوضع الذي تنهره فيه
الهدنه ومن ما يهدد السلم هنا في باكستان
وكذلك
احتمالات الهجمات الارهابيه صعبه
باكستاني سوف يردون بقوه وسوف يعملون على
سحق اي محاوله لتسبب بعدم الاستقرار داخل
باكستان من اسلام اباد جاويد صديق مدير
وتحرير الصحيفه الدينيشن شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه العنف يلاحق
المدنيين في الصومال وهجوم جديد لحركه
الشباب
مرحبا بكم من جديد نتبع من السودان حيث
اصدر رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان قرارا بتجميد النشاط
السياده
اصحاب العمل وشمال القراره تحديدا
وحسابات النقابات داخل وخارج السودان
ووضعها تحت السيطره
من الخرطوم معنا مراسله لينا يعقوب لينا
اهلا بك معنا المزيد من التفاصيل حول قرار
تجميد النقابات المهنيه في السودان
وخلفياته ايضا
مساء الخير عليكم صهيب ربما لاحظنا خلال
الايام الماضيه وكذلك في الفترات الماضيه
ان هناك عمل وحراسي هذه النقابات المهنيه
وكذلك للاتحادات سواء كانت هذه الاتحادات
محسوبه على النظام السابق مثل الاتحاد
الصحفيين او بعض النقابات المهنيه واللجان
مثل لجنه المعلمين التي نفذ اضرابا في
المدارس الحكوميه اليوم هذا القرار ياتي
لالغاء كل هذه الاتحادات وكل النقابات على
اي خلفيه كانت انتماءاتها او على اي فتره
وان كان في قطارات النظام المعزول او حتى
خلال هذه الفتره او عمل
الانتقاليه
او هل هناك اي رده فعل من هذه النقابات
حتى اللحظه لن تصدر ردود افعال الرسميه
ولكن مثلا
نجمه تفسيريه لنقابه المحامين قد تعلن عن
موقفها كان يفترض ان يكون لديها مؤتمر
ايضا صحفي بعد غد بالتالي نحن نتوقع ان
تعقد لجنه اللجنه التسيريه لنقابه
المحامين او النقابات المعزوله او حتى
الاتحادات
المجمده ان تعلن عن مؤتمر صحفي وتوضح فيه
موقفها من هذا القرار الذي ايضا استند على
توفي من لجنه تعمل طبعا صهيب من المعلومه
انه تم تشكيل لجنه اخرى فيها ممثل لي
وزاره العدل وكذلك ممثل النائب العام
وممثل ديوان المراجعه لكي تقوم هذه اللجنه
والاشراف على اللجان التي تشكل خلال
الفتره المقبله لذلك يبدو ان هناك عمل
قانون
قانوني اخر همم يرفض هذا القرار همم قد
يتضح وتظهر همم يظهر بصوره اكبر خلاله
الفتره المقبله لما يعقوب من الخرطوم شكرا
جزيلا
[موسيقى]
وافريقيا ايضا اعلنت الشرطه الصوماليه
مقتل تسعه اشخاص بينهم مدنيين في هجوم
لحركه الشباب الصوماليه على فندق في
العاصمه مقديش واضافه الشرطه وانها نجحت
في تحرير 60 رهينه تحتجزها مسلحون من حركه
الشباب مشيره الى ان عمليه تنشيط الفندق
انتهت
شكرا لك ليليان البيت الابيض في هذا الخبر
العاجل نراقب ما اذا كانت تويتر سيتحول
الى اداه تضليل هذا اخر خبر عاجل وتذكير
بابرز العناوين الان
في ايران احتجاج صامت لكن رسالته كسرت كل
الحواجز وجنرال ليقر بمقتل اكثر من 300
شخص في الاحتجاجات اله الناس كيف يفتحوا
النار على اقل ويؤكد ان الشركه هددت بحجم
تويتر من مجارها ويستهمها باخذ ضريبه سريه
مباريات النحاسمه في كاس العالم البرازيل
يحدث مقعده في دور ال 16 والتفوق اللافته
للفرق الافريقيه مجلس السياده السوداني
يشدد الخناقه على النقابات المهنيه وقفوا
انشطه وحفر ارصده وسلب للسلطان
[موسيقى]